here are some celebrities who have to
financially support their family as
child actors Cole Sprouse recently
shared that The Suite Life of Zack and
Cody was a life-saving show for him and
his brother by the time they were 10
years old their mother had spent all
their money from their previous acting
gigs their father was given forced
custody and they were struggling
financially but once Cole and Dylan
started working with Disney Channel it
provided them the financial stability
that their family needed Bella Thorne
only took a role in Shake It Up because
if she didn't her family would have been
out on the street her mom had debt and
was a single mom of four kids she said
before she landed her world and Shake It
Up her family was living off coupons for
frozen meals when Kiki Palmer's acting
career took off she became the
breadwinner of her family she wanted to
support her career which meant they
couldn't really have their own jobs
because one parent had to be on set with
Kiki and the other one had to be
watching over her three siblings so this
left Kiki has the breadwinner Leighton
Meester used to give her mom a monthly
allowance of seven thousand and five
hundred dollars to cover her brother's
medical expenses but then her mom
threatened to sue her if she didn't
raise it to ten thousand dollars a month
and then Layton sued her mother for
using the money on herself but Leighton
won her suit which freed her from
Financial Obligations to her mother